um all right
um welcome to the ddk seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
today let's go over some rules and
Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk and please use
chat room to post your questions so that
you can address them in Q a session at
the end a second today's gdpr seminar is
open to external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out finally The
Talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel that's about it
let me introduce our speaker today it is
an honor to host Thomas Beckers who is
an assistant professor of computer
science and Institute for soft software
Integrated Systems at Vanderbilt
University before joining Vanderbilt he
was a postdoctoral researcher at the
department of electrical and systems
engineering University of Pennsylvania
where he was the main member of the
grasp lab and precise and onset Center
in 2020 he earned his Doctorate in
electrical engineering at the Technical
University of Munich Germany he received
the BSC and the MSC degree in the
electrical engineering in 2010 and 2013
respectively from the Technical
University of Brunswick wake also in
Germany in 2018 it was a visiting
researcher at the University of
California Berkeley very close from here
and he is a DOT allnet fellow and was
awarded with the world
towards outstanding dissertation price
his research interests include
physics enhanced learning non-parametric
models and safe learning based control
today Thomas will present an exciting
topic which is physics enhanced the
ocean process for learning of
electromagnet electromechanical systems
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further Ado let me pass the
button to Thomas by asking one random
question today's random question is what
is your idea of the perfect day
all right first of all thank you very
much for the kind introduction and yeah
so my perfect day since you said I'm
coming from Germany like from Munich so
Munich is very close to the Arts so
great mountains and I really love hiking
so my perfect day would definitely first
start with a
with a good breakfast with eggs and
bacon you know and then like a nice
hiking trip the best case would be in
the mountains um having wonderful sunny
weather and yeah having a great day
Outdoors nice sounds like uh my perfect
day as well all right because the stage
is yours Thomas thank you very much yes
um yeah as I said thank you for the kind
introduction and um yeah my name is
Thomas Perkins and yeah today I want to
present our work on physical enhanced
housing processes for learning of
electromechanical systems and um yeah in
general
um so my background is in control theory
so I'm coming from like the idea of safe
learning based control
and so recently we started to think
about like how can we make that possible
but let me start with the motivation so
when we think about today's systems
then we can we noticed that actually the
complexity is more and more growing of
these systems you see here two nice
example of uh very nice uh
electromechanical system so on the left
side there's a new humanoid robot from
Boston Dynamics and you see like complex
structure and Dynamics here on the right
side a bio-inspired robot from festo
with new materials a new activation
concept and you can imagine that
actually the control of these robots of
these systems is very challenging at
least it's very time consuming
and it definitely requires expert
knowledge so we have to come up with
models of these systems with a
controller and it's very very complex
however I mean you can also see with
perspective amount of theoretical work
and experimental evaluations we can
control these systems right you see like
this how this robot jumps uh how this
robot on the right side is activated and
can equip objects but the problem is
that sometimes we still fail
and we might fail because we are not
able to consider like all part of the
System Dynamics sufficiently accurate
so our models as you know are never
perfect so there's always a mismatch
between the model of the system and the
actual system and this can be a in
control so if you use this model to
control the system this can lead to some
yeah issues as you can see and the
videos on the left side again the Boston
Dynamics robot and you see at some point
he steps on some soft material here
right at the moment so and these are
these are part in the dynamic of the
system or in the environment that we are
not able to capture in our model because
it's too complex because it's very
non-linear or just too time consuming to
model all these um things
so that means that we have always a
troubled to find good models or that
we're never able to really get the
perfect model due to two complex
Dynamics in our system due to some soft
materials for example or just like new
environments like on the right side so
maybe there's like some wind and so my
my drone crashed here
and what we could experience in the last
decade that machine learning is here a
very promising approach to tackle this
issue so the idea is instead of using
first principle models so using like
standard physics like Odes
to come up with a model of these systems
we're using data so we collect data of
the system and then be using some
machine learning models
and we use this model then for coming up
with a controller and here you see three
examples so the first one is actually
already quite old so this is a robot
which learns how to flip pancakes and
with reinforcement learning approach and
so here we use the machine learning
model
to learn the Dynamics of the pancake and
you can imagine that like these Dynamics
are pretty hard to write down just by
hand
another example you might know from
deepmind also already some years ago
where we use reinforcement learning to
learn how to activate the stickman so he
can walk and even jump over obstacles
and more recent example from a robotic
hand from openai which learns how to
actually many manipulate this Rubik Cube
and also here you can imagine that like
a model for this Rubik Cube is quite
hard because you see you have some slips
you have uncertainties and so very very
complex model
but you can also see is that actually
all these systems are not very safety
critical right so I mean like with a
pancake maybe you you have a bad
breakfast if it's gone if it's go wrong
but
um I mean it's not safely critical right
and with the stickman Rubik Cube so it's
mostly like toy examples and what's the
reason here I think one of the main
reasons is that most of our machine
learning techniques so far are mostly
Black Box models right so we don't
really know when they work and how good
they work I mean we just hope that if we
have enough data then they're gonna be
good enough
so am I actually research focused and so
also my my research vision is actually
how we can establish safe and robust
control of totally unknown or at least
partially unknown physical systems which
means that we do not know the Dynamics
we don't have a good model of the system
so how can we come up with a good
controller
and everything like getting a good
controller always is based on having a
good bottle of the system
so and I think what we need is first of
all we should definitely include the
prior knowledge we have about the system
because especially like electrical
electromechanical systems we have a lot
of fire knowledge about it I mean we
know um there are some Physics in the
background right so we have Newton's law
we have energy conservation and all
these
um physics in the background so we
should think about what we know
and definitely include this knowledge as
prior knowledge in our learning
processes
then we always have a part that we do
not know these can be some uncertainties
this can be an electromechanical system
for example friction which is really
hard to model so these are typically
Parts which are not captured by our
models but are in our assistance but we
can't really model it so these are the
parts we do not know about the actual
system dynamic
and now comes the important part the
important part is to come up with safe
control so to get some guarantees if I
can actually control my system or not
and that's a part of that we need some
uncertainty quantifications so we
definitely need to know what we don't
know right so that means if you have a
model it's not enough to get some
predictions of this model we also need
to know like how certain the predictions
are so can we really trust the model I
mean in best case we have a trustworthy
model but at least we want to know in
case if our model is not trustworthy
because then we can think about
strategies how to still guarantee the
safety but at least we have to know if
our model is trustworthy or when it's
not prosperity
okay so and
um the outline of this talk is
um so the normal pipeline what we do in
control as I said is that we have our
system here
from the system we come up with some
model and here we focus on data driven
models and then we use these models and
control but today I just want to talk
about this left part so when we have
electric mechanical system and we
collect data
how we can come up with the data driven
model how we can include trial knowledge
into this model
and um so first of all I will introduce
gaussian processes because the title of
the talk also includes thousand
processes so you can imagine we're
working here with um these processes as
a machine learning model
and then the first part of the talk is
then uh um I will introduce gaussian
process part hamiltonian systems this is
which is some class of uh yeah physics
enhanced data group model we use
and in the second part I will talk about
gaussian process variation and auto
encoder
okay so before I dive into gaussian
processes let me
start again with why we want to have
physical informed learning so as I said
in control we have like two different
concepts of how we can output the
control so both Concepts is always the
idea I have my control Loop for example
I want to control a robot
um and I have to come up with a
controller so I'm typically guys start
with some model of the system and when I
talk about the model so we have um
normally talk about an ode model okay so
a bunch of equation of all the ear
creation and we have two different ways
actually how to do that so the first one
is like physic based and that's the way
we did like in the last a hundred years
I would say
and the right side is learning based
okay and let's start with physic-based
so what are what are the benefits of a
physic-based model okay so really where
I can write down the Odes of the system
so first of all it generalized well
right I can actually evaluate this model
on all points
so I'm not focused on a specific area if
I have this model I can guarantee like
some performance and stability
properties of my clothes Loop so I go
don't go into the details so but in
control theory we have a really strong
math
background how we can guarantee specific
performance if we know that the model is
correct or at least we know that the
model is like almost correct so if we
have some uncertain quantification then
we can tell you how good this control
Loop works
the problem is or with the model
selection as I said
um when we want to model friction for
example friction is very complex concept
or just general non-linearities in our
system so what kind of model do we use
yeah or if you think about which is also
like an interesting topic at the moment
like human robot collaboration like
exoskeletons and so on so we have the
human envelope so how can we murder the
human and with equations right so this
is pretty pretty tough problem
and it's also time consuming so if you
want to get a good model of a robot of a
quadcopter of whatever kind of system
it's really time consuming you need
expert knowledge and a lot of time to
come up with an accurate model
on the other hand side think about
learning based approaches so instead of
coming up with a physical model we
collect data of our system
and for example
in real Network or whatever kind of
machine learning model and we use this
machine learning model then to come up
with a controller and you know they
these models are highly flexible
normally we just need minimal expert
knowledge so we can like in the simplest
approach we can just use a standard
neural network collect data using some
toolbox and then we have some kind of
model right the problem is
you do not know how if it generalized
well so normally we assume okay like
around my training data it's hopefully
kind kind of works well but outside this
regime I have no idea what happened
actually
and like as I said so these are
typically Black Box models so we just
get some output we do not know how
trustworthy this model is we have no
uncertainty quantification so we in this
case we cannot really give stability or
any performance guarantee
and so um yeah if I kind of natural to
think about okay how can we bring
together The Best of Both Worlds how can
we bring together like the
um guarantees from physic-based model
together with the flexibility of
learning based models and this was for
me the motivation to start looking into
physics enhanced learning
okay so
um yeah let me introduce
um
our first problem statement
so we think here or we want to talk here
about electromechanical systems which
can be expressed as some type of ode
function here
and we are input is fine you see with
here the um f function so the Dynamics
and then an input Matrix G here and an
input U okay and X is the state of the
system for example the position and
velocity of your mechanical system
um then we actually observe this system
um and we collected data and our data
consists of this of a timestamp so for
example every second we we call the
state of the system and the state can be
corrupted by noise this is that's very
typically for example if I have sensors
on my system I always have some noise in
my measurement so we assume we can have
here some gaussian noise zero mean
gaussian noise on the state measurement
okay and then over time I collect some
State measurements and this is actually
my data set and I also incorporate the
input to my system for example if I have
a motor this would be for example the
torque of the motor to the robot
and when I talk here about
electromechanical systems I think it's
important to mention here that these
kind of systems are typically low
dimensional so we talk about like
I don't know two to maybe 10 12 States
so these are the typical systems we're
dealing with but often highly non-linear
because we have like these non-linear
um materials or non-linear elements in
our system so it's low dimensional but
highly non-linear
okay and the problem is now given this
data set D we aim to find a dynamic
model
of our system which first represents a
large class of systems so we want to
keep the flexibility so we want to come
up with a physical informed machine
learning model which is flexible so
which I can use for a different type of
electromechanical system so it should be
expressive then as I said we are in
control we are interested in uncertainty
quantification because at the end of the
world when we want to use these models
in control we need these uncertainty
quantification to give guarantees about
the performance of the controller so
we're looking for model which is
reliable or at least it should tell us
if it's trustworthy or not
and then the last point is that it
should respect physics so it should and
if it's respective physics it
generalized well right so then we can
use
um the model not only close to the
training data but also if you have fast
training data or if we're in on areas
without much training data
okay and yeah now okay we we decided we
want to do some physical informed
learning right but so what's our machine
learning model here
and uh yeah a quick overview very very
simplified overview I would say about
different models and here on the x-axis
you see the expressivity
and here if we have any kind of
uncertainty quantification and first of
all we can think about parametric models
right so for example a simple linear
model you know you have two parameters A
and B and you can do like um least
square and then you have like this
regression model it's very simple but
not very expressive and does not have
any uncertainty quantification
new networks of course Very expressive
can deal with large data sets but at
least in the plain form we also have no
uncertainty quantification and then we
have like the whole
um part of Bayesian parametric models
right so where A and B you put some
prior distributions On A and B and you
can um yeah use based ethereum to get a
posterior distribution you know and then
you have a regression actually with some
uncertainty quantification again same
problem it's not very expressive even if
we have more
complex parametric model but it's still
like mostly simple model
and then we have like we can combine the
best of both words kind of and these are
gaussian processes so in gaussian
processes actually allows us to include
trial knowledge in a very nice way it's
a non-parametric technique which means
it's actually very flexible and it gives
us uncertainty quantity application we
want to see
okay so let me talk more about gaussian
process because this is a very Central
Point for for this talk we use it like
in both approaches
so the idea of a gaussian process is
actually that the government process is
a distribution of a function space so
you can think about like a gaussian
distributed variable which is fully
defined by a mean and a variant right
and now you make it dependent over some
index set for example the real numbers
so to make it a function and so you have
to like you can describe a gaussian
process by a mean function here M of X
and some covariance function so what's a
covariance between two points in your
input space
the point of the gaussian process is
that if you you have now like a function
or infinite number of
um random variables and if you pick any
finite set of these random variables
it's always jointly gaussian distributed
okay so if you pick two for example two
variables they're join the Gauss and
distribute it here
and this means um so let's assume we
have some index here here our input X
and some output y
and in red here this Red Line is now our
mean the gray is our uncertainty
and now if you pick like two
um
variables here random variables so one
at location x one the other one at
location X2 so we have the random
variable y1 and Y2
so what's now
um the the joint distribution it's a
gaussian distribution as I said we see
here the mean functions and here the
covariance function between these two
points in the input space okay so any
finite set of a thousand process all of
the gaussian distribution
and now what we can do with this
gaussian process is we can use it for
regression and the idea is the following
so we use base theorem which means we
start with some fire distribution which
can hear this zero mean distribution
then we collect data
and based on this data we update the
fire and we get the posterior right so
that's the idea of Base Theory
and that's what we do here so you see an
example on the right side
when I collect data
um I
um yeah improve my prediction and what
you can see here again in Grace the
uncertainty and we have now one data
point and what you can see the
uncertainty here around this data point
is decreasing which makes sense because
we have data so our model tells us okay
I'm actually very certain here about my
prediction and these colored lines and
our samples from the gaussian process so
each stamp of a gaussian process is a
function it's a deterministic function
and each function is like one
possibility right
um based on the data you collected and
what you can see if you collect more
data your uncertainty is decreasing
which makes sense right and all these
samples you drew from the government
process coming closer and closer because
you're most certain about the actual
underlying function right and if you
have a lot of data it can be noisy data
and then this uncertainty is very small
and you're very certain about your
output okay and so if you want to do a
prediction if we have collected data and
we want to do a prediction for a new
test input X Star
based on a training set D okay capital x
is here the position of your the input
position of your data capital Y is the
output position of your data
then we get like two we get a very nice
analytic closed form solution here
that's also a nice property of a
gaussian process so you get a closed
form solution for the prediction and
again same thing since it's gaussian
distributed it's fully defined by the
mean and the variance so what you see
here is now the posterior distribution
okay so the mean for the output given a
test input and your data set d
and what you can see on the on the right
side here this equation you see the the
prior mean this m function you see the
covariance function again the covariance
tells you how related at two points in
your input space so I have the
covariance between my test input and my
training data set capital x then here I
have my covariance of the training data
so of capital x and here my output data
capital Y okay so you see it's a very
kind of simple function what you get as
close form solution for the posterior
one of the drawbacks of gaussian
processes you can directly see here and
what you see here is that you have to
compute the inverse of this covariance
Matrix okay and this inverse The
covariance Matrix like the dimension
depends on how much data you have so if
you have more data then you have to take
an inverse of a very large Matrix okay
so there are different approaches how to
reduce
um this but yeah I I don't want to talk
about the details but normally this is
some kind of drawback of a gaussian code
okay and um yeah to think about the
gaussian process we can also thing from
a perspective of linear regression so
you can think about that you have some
training data so you want to do a
Bayesian linear regression so you have a
linear function you put a prior a
gaussian prior on the weights on these
W's
you have some measurements of this
unknown function again corrupted by some
gaussian noise
and then as we know I mean by doing some
math in the background we can come up
with this standard expression for
Bayesian linear regression right so
again it's a normal distribution given
our data set given some input point the
the
distribution of the output is gaussian
defined by a mean and by some variant
okay so this standard page linear
regression and what now happens or what
you can think about the gaussian process
so what we do is we kind of transform
Bayesian linear regression in a higher
dimensional space so you can think about
it
for example if we it's easier to think
about it like from the perspective of
classification so imagine we want to
find a
uh linear function to separate like
these two points okay these these
squares and this circle again it's not
working like in these two dimensional
space but what we can do is we can lift
it to a three-dimensional space for
example here to this sphere and here we
can easily find a linear plane to
separate these two
um training data sets okay and that's
the idea actually what what you can
think about is about the gaussian
process is doing we're doing Bayesian
linear regression but in a higher
dimensional space and this higher
dimensional space is actually defined by
some feature map so you have some
mapping from this lower dimensional
space to this higher dimensional space
and instead of using like the X the
input we just now use this feature
mapping from the input okay so we do
this transformation from the input to
the higher dimensional feature space
and and the nice thing is here because
when you remember like in the in the
posterior distribution of the gaussian
process you uh didn't see this feature
map and the point is that you we
actually don't really uh need to know
this feature map because it turns out
that if you put it like in this equation
here from Bayesian linear regression
that it always appears as inner product
so the only thing we need is the inner
product of the feature map and this is
exactly the kernel function or the so
from a Bayesian perspective we think
about it as covariance from a machine
learning perspective this is often
called a kernel function okay
okay so that was like the the quick
introduction in into the gaussian
processes and now really the part like
how can we incorporate trial knowledge
into the gaussian process and when we
take a look on the mean function so this
is like this again the posterior mean
um expression for the gaussian process
it's slightly different uh it's written
in a slightly different way but here
again I have the firemine and here this
part is now written as the sum over the
number of data points here's my
covariance function and this weighting
effector depends on on the collected
data okay and if you see this equation
you can directly come up with two ways
how to incorporate training uh prior
knowledge first one is by the mean
function right so you can think about
um including some parametric model as
mean function and this would act as some
guidance right so without data we would
follow your mean function but as soon
you have data you trust like or you rely
on the data and you can diverge from
your mean function
the other way is via this kernel
function or
covariance function right so we can also
think about how can we design this
covariance function okay and this is
different from the mean function because
as I said the covariance function is
connected to this feature map like where
you lift your basal linear regression
here
so this means this covariance function
actually defines the class of functions
of your gaussian process so let me give
you here
some example so if you have some
training data points
a very simple covariance function is the
so-called linear covariance function and
this kernel function actually defines
the space of linear functions so which
means like every posterior mean of a
gaussian process is always a linear
function okay so you limit the class of
regression so or you limit the the
function class for a regression to
linear function
and from the machine Learning Community
we got very or we get many like
different kernel functions for example
the so-called mutton kernel which
defines the
um the smoothness of your function so
you can say okay you can reduce your
function class to a one-time
differentiable function or two times
differentiable function and so on and
also this great exponential kernel which
is a very popular kernel which generates
always smooth function so this is a
class of smooth functions okay but so
far this is like a perspective like a
function perspective so what are the
properties of your function but how can
we now actually include physics okay so
how can we encode physics
and the idea is here that we come up
with a very General Physics model okay
and what we what we chose is the glass
of power hamiltonian system so this is a
very general framework how to describe a
physical system especially
electromechanical system
I'm sure you all heard about hamiltonian
systems and this hamiltonian system is a
specific form of support hamiltonian
system so protein system are some kind
of an extension of hamiltonian system
but it's the same idea we have some
hamiltonian function which is like the
general energy in your function
but now we have some interconnection
Matrix and this interconnection Matrix
defines the internal flow of your energy
for example thinking about the pendulum
it would defines like how the energy
flows on kinetic energy to the potential
energy in the system
then in contrast to a hamiltonian system
we can also have some dissipation in our
system okay and this defined by this
Matrix R for example if we're friction
it would be part of this Matrix r
then we have some input Matrix G and
some output y of our system
and partometerine system have some very
nice properties
um so J is Q symmetric by definition and
this always ensures energy conservation
so at least if we have no dissipations
of R is zero then we have energy
conservation then the energy is always
constant
the input and output defines a passive
system
and we can connect different port
hamiltonian system and get again a
pot-hemitonin system so we preserve the
structure
and finally
um like since it's like an energy driven
model it's very suitable for
multi-domain applications so it's very
easy to connect electrical system with a
mechanical system because it's
everything is under the big umbrella of
an energy of the total energy of the
system
okay and our idea now was like that we
have data from some kind of physical
system we collect this data and then we
try to learn such an import hamiltonian
system in connection with the gaussian
process model and the idea is that we
put a gaussian process prior on the
hamiltonian so we use the gaussian
process to learn the energy of the
function
and we also
um do some parameter estimation for
these Matrix matrices J R and G okay so
we assume we have no knowledge at all
about the energy of the system but we
assume we have some at least structural
knowledge about these matrices J R and G
which are typically kind of simple
but we can learn
um parameters in these matrices
okay and so we come up with a physics
and form gaussian process model since we
we use like this underlying part-time
returning systems in the gaussian
process
and what we get here is you can think
about if we Now sample from this
gaussian process model it gives you some
kind of distribution about all possible
part-time returning systems under this
GP prior okay so you can think about
instead of just getting one model you
get like a distribution about model
but each model itself is like physically
correct because there's always this
underlying Port hamiltonian system so we
will see an example on the next slide so
let me explain the the pipeline here so
again we have our system we collect a
state of our system over time
but the first step is what we do we use
some filter to come from the time and
state information to state state
derivative okay so like in like other
approaches what we actually need is like
we need the state and the state
derivative to do the regression with the
gaussian process so we can use some kind
of filter we use here gaussian process
but the at least in control and there
are many other features
um you can use then we have our gaussian
process to learn the hamiltonian we'll
learn we are able to learn some
parameters in our matrices
and after the learning process we sample
from this gaussian process so for
example we can draw 10 samples
so we get like 10 deterministic Port
hamiltonian systems
then what we have to do is doing some
approximation to make it more
computational tractable and then we put
this in an ode solver and then we get
trajectories like from our 10 standard
Port hamiltonian system okay and each
trajectory is like one possible model
based on the data we collected okay and
if we collect more data this
trajectories are closer together if we
have less data then of course we see
more fluctuation between these models
okay
um
I think I speed up a little bit so that
we can also come to the second part of
the talk so
as I said we have here the the filters
on the only purpose of this data is that
we come from time State information or
um data to state state derivative and
what we do is simply we um yeah use the
time and States we fit the gaussian
process into this data and then we take
the derivative of a gaussian process
since it's a close Chrome solution it's
easy to take the derivative you can
directly take the derivative of the the
covariance
and what we get is then the mean
prediction for the state and immune
prediction for the state derivative and
so we can create a new data set with the
state information again for example like
the position and velocity of the robot
and the derivative like the velocity and
the acceleration
and then the the actual core of the
support
um we put a GP prior then on the port
hamiltonian system.net what we get is
then
um a new kernel function okay and this
kind of function is like inspired or
includes these Port hamiltonian systems
and structure and so we have like a
gaussian process for the right hand side
of our ode
and what we use here is the property of
a gaussian process that is closed under
linear operator which means if G here is
a gaussian process and you have a linear
operator acting on your on your process
then you can include that in the process
and F is again a gaussian process okay
it's the same like a gaussian
distributed variable if you have a
linear operator on the gaussian
distributed variable
um like it's again a gaussian
distribution right so if x is gaussian
distributed a times x is also golden
distributed
and that's the sample gaussian processes
so for example we can have the
differential operator and we can include
it in the kernel function and then what
we could do is for example if we do
function regression but we do not have
as training data as a function values
but the derivative of these function of
this function at some positions right
where you can take the derivatives and
then it do a prediction of the value of
course plus minus some constant but so
we can easily combine everything with
the a linear operator and that's exactly
what we do for the port hamiltonian
system chroner because remembering the
structure of a potamertonian system so
everything before this hamiltonian
function is actually linear operator so
we have the derivative we have the
multiplication with J and R so this is a
linear operator on the hamiltonian so
this means here in the center of our
current function we have this great
exponential kernel because we use here
is great exponential because we know the
hamiltonian is actually a smooth
function and then we use the linear
operator which is here the J and the r
Matrix and the derivative with respect
to X and so we can come up with a new
covariance function which now includes
the sport hamiltonian structure
okay and as I said
um if we have some unknown parameters in
our matrices Jr and so on we can
actually treat these parameters as hyper
parameters in the learning process okay
so we can learn it so engage in process
you use the log likelihood function you
optimize a lot like load function to get
the parameters which describe best our
data
and so you can treat all parameters as
hyper parameters and then we come up
with uh yeah this current function which
is actually distribution over Port
hamiltonian system
okay so this was the The Learning part
so this pretty nice I think because it's
a closed form solution for everything
then
for the sampling after we collected data
and we did the learning now to get
actually predictions from your model
so what we do is
we now have to sample so and
the simple way would be to sample now
from this gaussian process which would
give you a deterministic function for
the right hand side of your ode okay
this would be one
sample of your Port hamiltonian gaussian
process
and so you could use this model put in
an OD solver and get the trajectory
however this is kind of computational
cost me I don't go here into the details
but what we do is then instead of
getting the entire right hand side
we
um learn or we sample the hamiltonian
okay so we do not get a sample from the
entire right hand side of the ode we
just sample a hamiltonian okay and then
we use some approximation technique for
the hamiltonian and then we put the
hamiltonian again in this potamatonin
structure
and then use an ode server
to get our trajectory Okay so the
takeaway message is here we sample the
the hamiltonian from our model and we
put it in the structure and then we have
a nice ode model so a deterministic
model for each sample we can put an OD
server and we get a trajectory
okay and for for this kind of protein
system we have also some theoretical
results so um again without going into
the details here um due to the time
constraints but what we can see is that
if we draw samples we actually get
potamatonin systems which have all the
nice property of normal hamiltonian
system now okay I I skipped you the idea
of the proof but this is similar to like
the proof of normal Port hamiltonian
system
and the other interesting property
especially from a learning perspective
is that it allows now composable
learning okay think about like you have
a big system like with many different
complex parts and now you can separate
your system and learn these parts
separately and at the end of the day you
can now combine your probabilistic model
with other probabilistic models and
again it's one big Port hamiltonian
system okay and still have this closed
form solution so this is this is a very
nice property
of this gaussian process
um what we use here
okay
um an example here so here within um
yeah like a toy example what we use here
is this red ball is some Island ball and
we have pure coil which creates a
magnetic field and when it creates a
magnetic field it attracts the ball
right and it's a nice electromechanical
system because you can imagine that the
inductance actually depends on the
position of the ball okay so like the
mechanics influence the electric and the
other way around
but so what happened if the ball rolled
around and we turn on this inductance or
this coil visualized here by by this red
color then it attracts the ball and so
yeah this is like a nice physical system
okay here we collect some data points
and now on the right hand side what you
can see is now our goes in process model
with four samples and this color no
three samples sorry and this colored
balls are now sampled of the gaussian
process okay of our protein system what
you can see here is like we have not
just like I don't know 20s 30 data
points so our models are quite different
but the point is that like each model is
physically correct so from the
perspective of Port hamiltonian systems
okay so each model is like correct um in
terms of the evolution of the energy
and if we collect more data like in this
example then of course our models are
closer together our uncertainty is
smaller and like the trajectories are
very similar okay so we get a nice model
with some kind of uncertainty
quantification because we can draw some
samples in HPC like what is the variance
among these samples
and yeah if we take a look on the
numerical results so the important
message here is what you can see as I
said that each model is physically
correct and if we take here a look
especially on the hamiltonian so the
dashed line is the actual system so the
real system and the colored lines are
now our samples from our gaussian
process model
and you can see here in the Red Square
so in this at this time we turned uh
turned off the coil so what we want to
observe here is that the energy is only
constant or decreasing right because we
don't put any external energy in this in
the system and you see that that's true
for all samples so and this is what I
meant by that the samples are physically
correct Okay so
um the the take-home messages here even
with sparse data or even without any
data or our samples are always like
physically correct and of course if you
have more data then your model is
getting closer and closer to the actual
system Behavior
okay and we feel some extension which I
just want to briefly mention so we
extend it to switching system for
example for this hopping robot where you
have switching Dynamics
in your system so we can come up with
switching for hamiltonian systems where
we use a gaussian process as as
classifier here uh in addition to our
known causing process for hamiltonian
system
and so we can also identify this hopping
robot and what we get from the GP
classifiers now it states Us in which
mode we are here for the hopping robot
we would have two modes we have one mode
where we are in contact with the ground
and another mode where are we where the
robot is in the air and so we have two
different Dynamics and with the GP
classified now tells us if we are in
mode 1 or mode 2 and again we can then
sample from this from this model and we
have like the very similar properties as
I showed you before
another extension is that so far we only
had parametric
um or we can only be only able to
estimate some parameters in our Jr and G
Matrix but this is some kind of
limitation because for example friction
would be some nonlinear function in your
arm Matrix okay so some complex function
okay not just like a parameter
um like yeah like in a very simple
friction model you just have I don't
know a parameter in front of your
velocity or something like that but
normally the friction is much more
complex so can we also like estimate
more complex
um elements here in our J and R Matrix
and the idea is here that since we love
gaussian processes so much we also put
now another gaussian process here in our
matrices okay and again we
um
we we have to think about how we can
guarantee this Q symmetry here of this J
Matrix and that this R Matrix is
positive but there are ways to do that
um
then what we get is that we can also
learn some non-linear friction for
example
the only problem is that we have since
we have now here got a gaussian process
and another gaussian process on the
energy whether multiplications of
gaussian and this not gaussian anymore
okay so in this structure we're losing
this nice close form solution
and we have to do some variational
inference to do some approximation here
to make this problem tractable but then
we can we can come up with a fully beige
model so we will not only learn the
energy of the system but also for
example the friction of the system
and here another toy example
um of a pendulum which goes here through
some water bowl and so we have some
friction as soon as the pendulum is in
the water which is like highly
non-linear depending of course on the
properties of the water on the shape and
so on
so we collect data here on the right
side you see the face diagram so the the
angle of the pendulum and the angular
velocity in red you see the actual
um the real
um system trajectory and then and yellow
now the learn system trajectory and the
green spots are data we collect so we
collect more and more data and you can
see even after like I don't know 30 40
data points we get already a pretty good
estimation and again here it's always
physically correct the only thing is how
good the model is okay and the color the
background color actually is the
uncertainty again here so the Blue Area
says it's very or certain and
yellow greenish area tells us it's more
uncertain okay and it makes sense
because then the error with training
data our model is more certain and in
the area without training data we have
more uncertainty
and here you see again the black line is
our model like that this is the energy
over the time and again we are always
like physically correct in terms of the
energy because the energy sorry is
always decreasing over time
okay
um this was the first part the second
part I tried to compress it to to that
we can also talk about this so the first
part was about polymertonian system the
second part is also again bringing
together fluid and gaussian process but
in a very different setting because so
far we assume we always have state
measurements right so we have some
sensors on our system for example
position sensors velocity sensors and we
get the state measurement but what if we
have like more High dimensional inputs
for example video okay so imagine you
have a pendulum and you take a video
and now we want to learn like these
Dynamics okay
so we have a high dimensional input
and yeah the goal is here now using
videos of your system
that we want to learn a low dimensional
Latin space
because for example with a pendulum we
know we can actually represent the
Dynamics like with two states
based on these videos and of course we
want to again have that these latent
space is physically correct so
respecting some prior knowledge and we
want to have our uncertainty
quantification
okay and the the motivation uh
motivational example is here imagine
that we have a car so we have a video of
a car for example going over a bumpy
road okay and we want to learn a low
dimensional representation for this
video frame okay and we can actually
Express such a video frame by two
variables the position so the battery
composition of the tire and the vertical
position of the car itself okay
but the thing is again here are some
Physics in the background right so there
is a coupling between the position of
the tire and the position of the car
right there are some Dynamics
um here based on the spring and the
damper right and so we think about how
can we actually make use of this trial
knowledge so maybe we know the Dynamics
of the car right because we designed the
car but what we don't know is actually
the external excitation of the of the
wheel okay so how can we include this
prior knowledge about the Dynamics about
the coupling of the wheel position and
the car position and so we were thinking
about like a physic enhanced variational
outer encoder to learn this low
dimensional Latin space
and yeah evaluation how to encode I
think I don't have to talk too much
about it I think you are I know how it
works right we have some high dimension
input data we have a network which
compressed this data to low dimensional
space and since it's operational
autoencoder another Classic Auto encoder
so we actually what we get is some
latent distribution so not a single
point but a distribution in this space
then we sample from this distribution
and then we have our output decoder and
we try to learn our or train our new
networks so that at the end we can
reconstruct the input
um through this pipeline right and then
we learned this low Dimension review
presentation from this high dimensional
space
and that's exactly now what we do
um but now with the gaussian process so
the idea is that we not only have one
picture but we have a video right so we
have a video we have like a picture over
time
and we use now gaussian process to
describe actually the evolution of the
object's position over time okay think
about like
um a simple example then the car think
about a ball okay so you have a video of
a ball right and so you can actually
represent like each frame by an X and Y
position of the ball right
so what we do is we have again an
encoder Network which compressed like
this High dimensional picture or frame
to the X and Y position or like a
distribution for the X and Y position
and then we have here now since its
Evolution over time right because the
ball is Flowing as
um it's going through the air so it's
like an evolution over time we have now
a gaussian process here
because we have like a different
position over time but there's some
correlations between the position right
so that's not like random but so we
would for example he assume uh a smooth
trajectory for example for the ball so
that's why we we can use here gaussian
process which actually describe the
position of the ball over time
then we sample from the gaussian process
okay and again we use an output decoder
and we train this entire network so that
the output we constructs the input okay
so the kind of the same idea of Auto
encoder but now like with an evolution
over time where instead of having like a
gaussian distribution
we have again like this gaussian process
to capture this Evolution over time
think about the physics now how can we
include the physics and that's now the
last step what we do here is when we
know that so this movement of the ball
is not like arbitrary but follows some
Dynamics we know that there might be
some or there is some unknown excitation
but there are some Dynamics in the
background right so like gravity and
like this stuff
and now we're using these Dynamics again
to come up with some kind of physics
inspired kernel and we use this kernel
function in the gaussian process okay
you can think about that we again define
a class of possible solutions of
possible trajectories for the ball
flying through there they are not
arbitrary we know they're following some
physics and we reduce the class of
possible solutions in the Latin Dynamics
based on these physics
okay I try to to come to an end to to
stay in this one hour
but so what we what we the goal is to
find the Latin Dynamics okay so we want
to find a Time series which are the
positions of the ball here this y
and the Dynamics should be expressed by
some linear Dynamics okay for example
gravity and so on so we have some
knowledge about or this is our prior
knowledge that there are some linear
Dynamics in the background which gives
our output but we do not know this
unknown exterior unknown excitation of
our system U for example the bombs in
the road
and what we do is we can write down the
joint distribution so the dawn
distribution between the video frames
and the Latin Dynamics or the video
different frames are described by a
large vector v here we do here with
black white videos
and the Latin Dynamics here why
and um
this is pretty much what we do with
variational auto encoders the
interesting point is here that you see
here the first half the we use a
Bernoulli distribution for modeling
these pixels the black white picks it
and on the right side you see again now
there's a gaussian distribution
over time and again this K function here
is our covariance which is this
physically enhanced kernel function okay
and now thinking about this current
function it's slightly different or it's
actually a big difference to our physic
enhanced kernel before because in the
port hamiltonian framework we learn the
right hand side of an ode and then we
put it in the ode server here we
directly want to generate the solution
over time okay so because like this GP
um defines or gives us the trajectory
over time and so what we want to learn
is the trajectory of the object over
time
which means we have some Dynamics in the
background as I said we have an input
which is unknown to us comes into the
Dynamics we get an output and so the
output defines the position of the
object
but what we can do if it's a linear
Dynamics we can again write it as a
linear operator okay so the linear
Dynamics we can express it with a greens
function and if you use the green
function with convolution on the input
you get the actual trajectory over time
so everything here is again a linear
operator on the input
okay and same idea we can now include
this in our kernel function so you see
here this K U1 to Kum
are currently times and so are again for
example spread exponential functions on
our input and then we have here this
linear operator this G function the
green functions and the convolution the
integral okay and so now the samples of
my gaussian process are solutions of my
Dynamic systems okay so trajectories of
my system
and we did it for for a simple system
here we assume we have a video of a
particle which has some Mass spring
damper Dynamics in the background and we
have some external excitation of this
particle and so this particle is like
floating around so this is the video we
actually observe from the particle
okay and so we collected a bunch of
videos I think we used here 50 50 videos
from this particle and then we put this
particle into the
um variational Auto encoder Pipeline
with the prior knowledge of the Dynamics
of the background but the GP is then
able to learn this unknown excitation of
the particle and what you can see here
are two examples now two new inputs
that's our original so the dark color
means here that's a start so this
particle would do like this circle uh
motion
and the light
um color means that's like the end point
of the particle
and on the left side of the input so the
original on the right side is now the
Reconstruction
um from the decoder Network and in
between is now the Latin Dynamics so the
crosses are the ground truth so that's
like the actual Dynamics which we know
here in our toy example but usually it's
unknown to us right and the red and blue
line are now the predictions for my
gaussian process okay and you'll see a
very nice predictions here with the
uncertainty bounds from the gaussian
process
what you can see if we compare it to
like the vanilla approach which means
you just lower gaussian process on the
entire system without any prior
knowledge
um you see now the difference so the
first row is using a standard gaussian
process to learn everything so without
the prior knowledge just using a
gaussian process again the crosses are
the ground truth the lines are now the
predictions of the gaussian process and
we just use training data in the first
30 microseconds
what you can see is that first of all
like just using the vanilla GP
after some training steps
um the actual prediction is not very
good
and what you see the uncertainty is
totally increasing when we are in an
area without training data which makes
sense right because like without
training data and without prior
knowledge we don't get a good prediction
but in the second row with our physical
inspired model
so we get a better prediction with the
same amount of data and you can see it
generalize very well in the area without
data so in the area after 30
microseconds so we get still a very nice
prediction even though we never
collected data in this time area right
but since we know there's like these
um fire knowledge about the Dynamics the
predictions are much better
okay so let me come to an end to to keep
the time so um the first part about of
the talk was about gaussian process Port
hamiltonian systems the idea is that I
get a distribute distribution about
physically correct systems and I can use
this systems
um to for example interconnect to other
Port hamiltonian systems and I
um keep these nice properties and each
model is physically correct
um independent of how much data I have
so even with less data it's correct but
maybe very bad but then I have the
uncertainty and um feedback and I know
it's bad but with more data I get more
and more certain and I know that now I
have a good model at the end
the second part was about the physic
enhanced gaussian process variational
Auto encoders here the idea is like
having a high dimensional input like a
video and using prior knowledge about
the Dynamics of the object to describe
the position over time of this object
and using this prior knowledge we can
improve the prediction quality and make
it more data efficient the whole process
and what's interesting but what we
haven't done so far is like if you train
this pipeline you can actually create
new videos right but you can change the
parameters for example in the dynamic
thinking about the car example
um you could change like the stiffness
of your spring or changing the damper
and then you can create new videos like
with different Dynamics in the
background and I think that's very nice
because then you can think about like
yeah seeing what happens if you if you
have different Dynamics how it looks
like and so on and so on
and yeah here I list some of the papers
um which covered um this result and my
website and my email thank you very much
well thank you Thomas for the nice talk
um well by the way it is okay to go
beyond the one hour okay
I still try to speed up a little bit so
that's not gonna be gonna be too late we
had a pretty long introduction sir
yeah you're you're pretty flexible on
that I mean the people can live because
if they have the other obligations but I
mean it is recorded so
um so we are going to upload this video
later
um so they can watch it later okay so I
wanted to focus on you get to you get
all the material you know you want to
recover in your presentation so that is
yeah that's that's awesome okay so let's
have a q a session
um although uh we have many people left
that's okay
um if you have any question I I don't
see any question in chat room so if you
have any question please help me then
ask questions
um
yeah um I can start
um okay so your model motivation I mean
you start with a robotic control so I I
thought
um it was about the control problem but
as I listen to you
um it's not so much about the control
and it's you have the data and you try
to improve the model as as you add the
more data using creation processing in
some sense it's a you're trying to get a
some sort of surrogate model
um and am I stating yeah yeah that's
totally correct as I said at the
beginning it's um it's like a two-step
process
what you normally do is like first
coming up with a good model and then
doing the control and actually yeah I'm
I mean I'm I'm also working on the
control part it's just like this talk
was focused just on on the modeling part
you're totally right I mean
um the the thing what I try to to make
clear is that as soon as we have a model
with uncertainty quantification then we
can use our well-known control pipeline
like for example if you're about NPC
control or any other kinds of control if
we have some knowledge about the quality
of the model then we can typically get
some robustness statements and I mean
that's also like my other big research
area like then what kind of statements
we can get here but yeah everything
starts like with with the model right so
um yeah maybe at some point I can have
another talk about the second part about
how to use them this mod is in control
in control okay I see
um yeah so I can see that you're really
fond of vacation process
um yeah
yeah but but as you know there are so
many other uh choices
um I'm wondering if you have compared
the case some some sort of comparison
study
yeah because we we do have the manual
options
uh yeah I mean I of course looked also
into other models and the thing is it I
think it kind of depends also on your
problems as I said I mean we are mostly
thinking about like low dimensional
problems with mostly sparse data
because I also like um from my previous
lab we had like many applications of
Robotics especially in um cooperation
with the human like um yeah human robot
interaction exoskeletons and all these
cases where you have typically very
sparse data set because the human don't
want to spend like hours coming up with
training data like with these first data
set I mean yeah I don't know for example
I tried Beijing Network or something
like that but it totally not gives the
same performance with like sparse data
set you need much much more data and
um yeah like in these settings like for
us it turns out that yeah the gaussian
process is actually the perfect approach
for us because I can like we are based
on the idea that you have the prior
knowledge right even if it's not
physical prior knowledge that you have
like smoothness knowledge also on that
you can come up with very good results
with sparse data and I don't know about
like too much other approaches where you
have this nice combination of sports
data of close form expressions and
um
what's the last thing I missed something
and yeah uncertainty quantification
[Music]
okay sounds good
um
well any questions from audience
we have a 13 of us
um
maybe maybe you wait for questions maybe
a comment
um you know maybe something to add here
I mean I I don't want to say that the
gaussian process is now the holy grail
for everything right
um I I totally want to just say that it
totally depends on your application
right of course if you have a lot of
data and you can think about other
things but yeah as I said like depending
on our applications also thinking about
that it should be like like you're
having a closed form Solution that's
also very nice thinking about using
these models in the control Loop that
you want to have some real-time
guarantees and so on so that's yeah many
things you have to think about
um yeah if you want to use it in control
settings all right that sounds good I
have another question about the the
training how long yeah usually does it
take to train this calcium process model
I mean not too long I mean the training
is then like
um about the getting the hyper
parameters right edits and it then like
I'm optimizing the log likelihood
function yeah and it it totally depends
on how much data you have as I said like
in the like vanilla form of a gaussian
process it actually skates a cubically
with a number of data so um this means
like normally you can nicely work with
like thousand to three thousand data
points and then it takes like minutes
maybe to to train it or even less
um but as soon if you have more data
then yeah it kind of explodes so then
you think have to think about either
um there are like many people who think
about how to speed up this thousand
process and there are already some
solutions how to make that possible or
really just using a totally different
model then I think if you have a lot of
data then of course neural networks are
a better choice I think
uh well training of the neural net is
it's not computationally yeah of course
yeah yeah
um is is it your code is available is it
open source that's not
um
like a open open source but we are
working on that we know that like in
machine learning you always have these
very nice toolboxes and everything
accessible and I think that's something
we have to work on in the control
Community but we are definitely working
on that uh yeah
um yeah yeah I hope we will get a nice
package out soon all right sounds good
but if some research group is interested
in your your model
um is it shareable
um yeah definitely if you're interested
please reach out I can at least send you
like the code of these toy examples and
so on so you can definitely see how it
works and work with it so yeah please
feel free to to reach out to me if you
have any questions about it or the code
or something all right sounds good all
right um is there any question from
audience
well if not let's think of our speaker
Thomas for the wonderful talk and nice
creation since well thank you Thomas
it's it's a real pleasure to having have
you yeah yeah
perhaps we are going to invite you again
we'll I can't talk
all right sounds good
okay let me
start the recording um